british drivers are accelerating towards
a carbon-free
future a ban on the sale of new petrol
and diesel cars
will arrive 10 years earlier than
planned so from 2030
charging stations like this in east
london will need to be the norm
not the exception
there is a long way to go it's estimated
22 million
charging points are needed just one in
six councils has installed any on-street
and a third of households have no
off-street parking
but the industry is confident it can
catch up the infrastructure is coming
and it will certainly be in place ready
for 2030. it's it's challenging in
places to install those charges
in every location but the key thing is
we need a balance of charging at home
for those who have driveways charging at
work and then lots of
adequate public charging too fast
charging points like these are an
important part of establishing a truly
national charging network but there's a
problem they require
a huge amount of power have a look at
this the power is coming into them from
this
red box it's been fed out in these
black cables but just look at the cable
that's bringing the power in
this huge black line runs all the way
back
to an electricity substation outside the
car park there's going to be huge
new demand on the national power network
if electric vehicles are going to be
truly viable in a decade
we're going to have to get smarter about
how we use power particularly at home
and this is what it might look like
these are some of the greenest council
houses in the country
built off-site in yorkshire by ilka and
assembled in woolwich
with solar panels feeding power back
into the grid
and an air source heat pump 12 times
less polluting than
gas laura and salius love it
if you can afford of course i believe
everyone wants to have this but because
it's not cheap
and well you you need to have finance to
to put those panels on and this to
to change all system to new system but
if everyone can do this why not i
recommend to everyone this every homes
heating will have to be transformed
and converting to hydrogen-powered
boilers and even entire communities
like this test site in cumbria will be
part of the answer
this is what the future looks like this
is what northern gas networks and the
other
industry players are really striving
towards to transition our network
to move hydrogen and move away from
natural gas
the government hopes it's laying the
groundwork for a greener future
we'll all notice the change if it's to
work
paul kelso sky news